do you think that i've been a good
parent
yes i know oh
well yeah
i know so like yeah i was in a school no
since school
in school you looked out for me and then
after school you just kind of said i was
stupid for doing what i do
[Music]
what's your relationship like
well i like to wind you up a lot and you
don't appreciate it no
what do you think
exactly you're a right prankster
aggravator
that's pretty much it i don't really
know that much about me
or you
no only the basics
anything you're nervous about asking
about
you know i'm not nervous about asking
i'm just nervous about the answer
if you switch genders for a day what's
the first thing you do play my boobs
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
how many people have you slept with
i don't want my mom to go there
right fair enough i don't ask no
i love this bug can i take this out
you have an idea of the number
four no
i could randomly guess five or six
have you ever seen me drunk yes
yeah well you drink anything every night
lock down pretty much that'd be stupid
you had a vodka on the way here
you're literally
truth game gaming that is the truth
oh god that's still good
on the way in really
i'm not last year
yeah
but then i don't really drink so i don't
really know
no this is women i don't really want to
drink either too honestly
when was the last time you had sex
oh sorry i bet the card
what's your favorite sex position
have you done any illegal drugs
cowboy
um
yeah
well you don't need to know what they
are i probably jamie wouldn't even know
what they are
that's right that's fine that's the
actual you wanna have fun
what's happening
it wednesday just to see what all the
fuss is about i've tried it but i don't
do it
what's the worst gift i've ever given
you that thing this christmas that silly
little flash
usb flashlight thing for a door when it
broke in two seconds but you bought one
for me and yourself yeah mine broke as
well but it's andy for winning
in the dark walking down the back garden
but it was like a 35 p thing off ebay
which before it's the fault in the it's
you it doesn't matter how much it costs
i think it was broken when it came
actually and you still wrapped up you
told me i'd have complained i'm 35
it wasn't 35 years old
get it right do you think that i've been
a good parent
yes i know
well yeah
i know so like yeah i was in a school no
since school
in school you looked out for me and then
after school you just kind of said i was
stupid for doing what i do
no but yeah but it was annoying it
survived it was encouraging though no
but i didn't so yeah i know basically
yeah yes i know there's that best
interest but also discouragement which
isn't it so a best interest is always
good it is
whether i was right or wrong i stole the
best interest i just wanted you to have
a backup i don't like it so the summit
goes wrong there's a backup
i had to do that she did it to me
what's your favorite sex position
i'm not i'm not answering that i am not
answering that
why not i don't want to explain loads to
you yeah and i didn't want to know you
can't be just man on top women need more
shut up mother look at my finger